I'm Siddhartha uni I'm a global shaper
from the Chennai hub I'm just here to
attend the World Economic Forum on India
2012 it's been like three days there's a
third day that I'm in this event and
it's been like fantastic to experience
the events here their programs were like
very well organized the panelists were
fantastic I happen to meet the best
people from the world here I ran into
mrs. sarah brown yesterday and we were
talking about how education is so
critical for the development of economy
and the children of India and we it so
it was such an equal platform because
you could walk up to anybody and just
talk your heart out and they will they
will actually take you seriously because
it's such a platform and it's a
congregation of the best people all of
the world so I think that's fantastic
and the press events where and you know
they were the panel discussions were
like so informative and it got me
thinking in a lot of different ways I
think that's the best part of about this
event and what else